what we're going to be covering in this
next topic is
doing what makes you happy aka following
your passion
yeah you know that whole way of life
versus how much money can i make
what's up with the money
where's the money
right so this story centers around
picking your college major so some of
you might be in college some of you
young folks might be going into college
some of your older folks have graduated
from college or maybe you've got student
loan debt but here's a little piece of
advice for the people picking their
college majors or people who've already
graduated and did a college major
this is a story by cnbc we all know who
they are and they basically highlight
these colleges
these college majors have the best r o i
david what's roi
return
on
investments
david
jesus christ
exactly trillionaire i promise not all
right maybe billing all right so these
colleges have the best roi david roi is
oh god
return on investment return on
investment david's pulling up the story
thank you
all right so off top here let me just
state this i'm not anti-college uh i'm
definitely not anti-education i am sort
of anti-taking out debt with no
understanding of how much you're taking
out and understanding about how much roi
here's a little stat for you college
graduates
on average will earn career earnings
earn double of what a high school
graduate will earn okay so i'm
definitely not saying don't go to
college it's not worth it i'm saying
you're gonna definitely earn more than
than high school grads yeah on average
you're gonna earn double so i think if
you go if lifetime earnings uh someone
can fact check this
high school graduates over their
lifetime will earn about a million bucks
okay
high school graduates yeah okay high
school back i mean that's nothing crazy
that's over the lifetime yeah that's
twenty five thousand dollars times forty
years yeah that makes sense okay of
course okay right um
college graduates on average will earn
two million bucks right that's
50 grand
50 grand times 40 years it's nothing out
of out of control right
let's talk about student loan debt right
the average federal student loan debt do
you know what the average federal
student loan does take a guess
dude it's got to be in the
billion 36 grand i'm talking about per
borrower oh i'm sorry i think you meant
total it's a little over a trillion but
yes 36 grand per borrow that's federal
and about if you're taking out private
student loans it's about 54 000. all
right cool let's clear the air let's set
the table for this conversation so you
know how how long on average it takes to
pay off student loan debt let me know in
the comments if you actually have an
idea of how long it takes to pay off
student loan debt david when you see the
numbers you just start reading them out
let me know and i'll get back to that so
here's the point of this article
certain majors are going to enable you
to have a higher rate of return a higher
roi return on investment than others
right roi david you might get a quiz
later homie
okay oh my god david
david's here more for his banter and for
knowing production not so much because
he
is
a um 60 40 60 uh production i see people
weighing in 15 years 15 years 25 years
it depends 10 years
20 years who said it
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship on
average correct it takes about 18 to 20
years on average to pay off student loan
debt but some
you could actually do it faster here's
the article
there are 11
bachelor's
degree programs bachelor degree programs
that allow most graduates to recoup the
money spent on their diploma in five
years or less so things are taking 18 to
20 years based on these majors you can
get it done in five best return on
investment what are those majors the
drum roll please
okay
out of the 11 7
are engineering majors
cha ching engineering majors dominate
this list
this includes engineering components
such as petroleum
aerospace and industrial engineering i
got a cousin he just graduated he's an
engineer i'm like good luck buddy i got
this article for you save that money so
the remaining majors other than
engineering are also in science
math and healthcare this includes
nursing
dental support services construction
management and quality control safety
technicians so these are the top majors
that you can expect the highest roi
right return on investment after going
to college so if you're you know people
say
you know i just want to do what makes me
happy right i just want to follow my
passion respect i get it nothing to you
but the whole point of going to college
is to obviously learn no doubt make
connections of course but so you can
have a career and make more money that's
sort of the point so on the flip side of
things flip side of things you might be
saying
i want to know what the
worst majors are when it comes to roi
god please don't say audio engineering
baby david oh my god that is about to
kill himself
oh my god oh well so here are the worse
they're the worst majors for roi
education okay right we all know that
teachers don't make all that much money
but they do get summers in spring break
off we get that media that's tv and
radio
damn communications
photography
and culinary arts
basically they're saying look bro you
don't take all of us in this office
you got something to do so
look
there's other fields that are actually
worse there's other fields such as drama
dance and the arts
that showed no roi most of the time
not a good look so look not my sister
was a was a musical theater drama major
the only money that she's made is the
money because she married a rich guy
he's a dentist all right right so talk
about that yeah right the only drama
she's bringing is family drama anyway so
if you're into drama and the dance and
the arts i get it but maybe
maybe you don't have to go to college to
learn how to act
maybe you don't got to go to college to
learn about music or how to dance people
are dancing on tick tock without college
degrees all day long so
here's the deal if you actually want to
figure out the rate the return on
investment
of your college major there's a little
formula that you could use there's a
little formula here's the formula if
you're taking notes i don't know if you
want to type this in here's the formula
the total career earnings
total career
divided by the total spent on the degree
times
a hundred
okay so the total career earnings so
let's say you make
three million dollars in your career you
divide that by the total you spent on
your degree right so let's say that's 50
grand
you add that up and you times it by 100
there's your roi and you obviously got
to do the roi over time it's not just in
one year over time in your working
career so there's a little tip that i
think will help you so look bottom line
is this people are going to say well
money isn't everything yeah that's true
i get it it's not everything people do
have jobs and fulfilling careers based
on whatever they want to do i get that
that's great i get it but it is kind of
important to know if you're ever going
to actually get your money's worth out
of your major if you're going to see a
positive roi because obviously going to
college and going to school is an
investment in your future
but just it's important to know what it
is and last thing is
just good luck out there now you got
some some tips that will help you
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken
[Music]